this video isn't about the science of
burnout
or how to identify if you have it
because you know
i'm not a licensed therapist or doctor
but what i do want to talk about
is a theory for why i think burnout is
so
common especially in the tech industry
on the anonymous professional networking
platform blind
61 percent of professionals in february
self-reporting themselves
as being burnt out and that number has
only risen to 73 percent
because of kovid three months after the
initial poll
some tech companies are notorious for
burning out their employees
and the platform has numerous threads of
folks sharing their
own burnout stories the unmanageable
workload
the expectation to constantly perform
perfectly
or the evaluation of performance based
on output which then creates this
toxic productivity focused work
environment these things
are not entirely uncommon in the tech
industry i've experienced burnout in
basically
every job that i've had so i was trying
to accept that it's just
a part of tech life but after i stepped
away from working in a corporate
environment
i thought does it have to be but first
let's define burnout because it can mean
a lot of different things
so basically in a nutshell that's how i
want to frame this video
it happens when the reward we get is not
worth the effort that we put in
this equation the balance between reward
and effort
is really what i want to focus on today
so let's talk about the effort side of
the equation
first i just want to say with like every
year that passes by
and the more that i learn about coding
in tech
i've concluded it takes a hell of a lot
of effort just to make something
not only does it take individuals to
learn and master technologies that are
current and state of the art
but they then need to use that knowledge
and spend hours and hours
building something that's probably never
existed before
in the same way that alone is a lot of
work
while on top of that all the
coordination and communication that
needs to happen before
any building takes place to make sure
that they're building the right thing to
begin with
which then is super subjective because
it depends on the product managers
designers
executives and anybody else with power
on
their goals and purpose for their work
then once it's
built making sure everything works okay
figuring out how to deliver the thing
telling users about the thing and then
finally
making sure it keeps working once it's
delivered
honestly sometimes i think it's a
miracle that things get built and that
we have the tech that we do
because in each step a lot of things can
go wrong
like realizing too late that you're
solving the wrong problem
or that something isn't technically
feasible or that two of the leaders of
your project
don't see eye to eye on how to solve a
problem because
one of them wants a promotion and the
other one wants to solve a problem for a
very specific user
so yeah creating technology takes a lot
of effort and a lot of things can go
wrong in the process that could prevent
something from being built at all
so already one side of the reward versus
effort equation
is pretty heavy so naturally i think a
lot of people would expect a lot of
reward
for that amount of work so now let's
talk about that side of the equation
what each of us see as rewarding is
completely subjective
and a lot of it is based on our
backgrounds personality
interests and values some people value
financial stability
others value the flexibility to do what
they want to in life
some value status and external
validation
and others are in pursuit of feeling
like they're making a difference in the
world
and the best thing is for each
individual to evaluate
what tangible goals these values
translate to
based on who they are and their own
situation
but what i've noticed is that in the
tech industry we tend to hype up the
same tangible goals
so things like getting a job at a fan
company making a big salary
getting a promotion or getting a job at
a mission-driven company
or what we've been able to think of so
far is how we know we've
made it underlying all of this obviously
are the values that are core to each
individual person
but for some reason we've accepted that
those goals are the ones that everybody
should strive for regardless of their
situation
it can be helpful to have quorum on how
our values manifest in the real world
like it can help spur inspiration or
help point towards a direction where we
might want to explore
it's the benefit of walking down a path
that's been walked down before
because we can use others journeys as
checkpoints for our own
even while so many people have their own
unique story
into the industry at the end of the day
it feels like
everyone ends up at a fang company at
some point
even if that's not true it sure feels
like it because that's how we framed
success
but i think when we internalize these
few paths our
imagination becomes limited and we start
believing that these paths
are like the only ones out there we
might forget what we
actually want for ourselves when we
start to see
other people's paths as our own and when
we achieve those goals that
we you know maybe didn't even really
want in the first place we feel
disappointed because the reward doesn't
come
and it just wasn't worth it my theory is
that this is precisely one of the many
causes of burnout in tech
if burnout is a failure to balance
reward and effort
we put a lot of effort in for work that
we end up realizing
are not really that rewarding for
ourselves
it can be difficult to manage this too
since you don't know if something's
going to be worth it or not until you
put in that effort first
i think this has a lot to do with why
the average tenure for a software
engineer
is two years as in after giving two
years of solid effort most people
evaluate whether this job is worth it or
not
i've seen this in my own career so far
one of the values that i use as my north
star
is to help people with the work that i
do so when i started to work at a
mission-driven company with a mission
i really aligned with i was ecstatic so
i poured my heart and soul into working
on the ios
app for them commuting three hours a day
for that job
but i realized two years later that the
leaders of this company didn't really
see the app that i worked on as a key
part of their strategy
and therefore my work wasn't actually
really helping anyone despite the work i
put in
burnout or when i worked at a fang
company because i was under the
impression that my work would reach
millions of people and make a big impact
so i poured my heart and soul into
working on features
collaborating with people from other
teams and then seeing that at the end
the work that i did didn't really feel
like it did anything
especially because it was hard to see
how it contributed to the product
outside of a few graphs that showed me a
few metrics moved by
tiny fractions of a percent burnout
and like i'm so grateful to have even
had these opportunities to begin with
because
i know not everyone does and it wasn't
like there was any one person
who was responsible for the outcome
either i kind of just
accepted that maybe this is just how it
is in tech
software engineering takes a lot of
effort i think that's true no matter
where you look in the industry
so the effort side of the burnout
equation is fixed
so what can we do about the other side
of the equation the reward
well for one the tech community is
always gonna hype up things it's just
the laws of popular culture but i think
we as individuals can view this from a
different lens to
help us better understand the industry
and ourselves
when you look closely at these things
that we're all supposedly striving for
there are fundamental rewards behind
them i think when people strive for the
common goals what they're really after
are
those rewards but burnout happens
because when they achieve them they
might not get the reward they were
expecting for the effort they put in
probably because they were pursuing a
goal they didn't really want in the
first place
so i guess my theory for one way to
alleviate burnout in tech
is for us as an industry to be more
imaginative
and challenge ourselves to find our
rewards through ways that feel authentic
to us heck there are plenty of people
who are doing this already
those who've never worked at fang those
who don't work in silicon valley maybe
have a traditional nine-to-five
and have found ways to navigate their
career in a way that feels authentic to
them how might we learn from them
and i think it's also important for each
of us to reflect on our current
situation and ask
is the reward i'm getting worth the
effort that i'm putting in
is it what i expected or wanted all
along managing that fine balance between
reward and effort is really tricky of
course the common ways that folks often
talk about curing burnout are a part of
this too
so taking vacations and taking breaks
and managing healthy relationships with
your coworkers
but i think the real first step is to do
that evaluation
am i getting the reward i expect for the
effort that i put in
it might be uncomfortable to sit with
that reality but i think
it's important to be honest with
ourselves and sit with that discomfort
rather than like
prioritize it away out of fear that
we're just simply not getting what we
put into our jobs
because when we say with it and we see
it we're able to start figuring out
what's going on in the first place and
that's always the first step once we can
do that
we can start imagining how we might make
changes big or small
to get the reward each of us need for
the effort we put in
sure it might mean pursuing something
that no one's done before
and that definitely comes with risk and
therefore is a privilege to actually go
after it but i know that we can't go on
like this until literally
everyone in the industry is burned out
because how are we going to use
technology to help society
if we're not helping ourselves speaking
of exploring what's out there
and being imaginative with what other
things you can do with technology
this video is sponsored by trends the
ultimate knowledge hub from the hustle
it's a community built for entrepreneurs
founders
investors and ambitious people to gather
learn
workshop and collaborate trends gives
you the information and network you need
to be successful
and it's a great place to jump start
your ideas and workshop with
like-minded builders i found it as a
great place to find
what's going on in different industries
like how the paper notebook business has
done
and also what trends you can trade on in
japan and
there's a ton of opportunities to
network with entrepreneurs and people
who are really thinking about what's
next in the industry
so right now you can get your first two
weeks for just one dollar
go to trends dot co slash my yuko
for your one dollar two week trial thank
you so much to transfer sponsoring
today's video
if you like this video then make sure to
subscribe and let me know what your
thoughts are about burnout in the
comments down below
i'll see you next time and take care
everybody bye